sind sie zu hause auch schon ganz
aufgeregt bald ist europawahl die
wichtigste europawahl die wir je hatten
am 26 mai entscheidet sich quasi das
schicksal des kontinents genau deswegen
hat unsere bundeskanzlerin jetzt
beschlossen in diesem wahlkampf gar
nicht aufzutreten
ja ja sie setzt einfach mal aus und
warum auch nicht warum ich
man muss ja nicht bei jedem quatsch
mitmachen wahlkampf und frau merkel hat
ja auch so genug wichtige termine was
die allein in den letzten tagen alles
gemacht hat
sie lässt sich auf messen erklären was
ein hobel macht sie zieht an der
längsten bockwurst der welt oder
eröffnet mit kindern neue windparks und
kriegt dann natürlich wieder das einzige
kaputte münchen das bild der
energiewende
doch sie ist das offizielle spiel zur
deutschen energiewende kostendruck
pusten
[Applaus]
wer vielleicht
vielleicht haben sie es gelesen in
manacor spricht jetzt erstmals offen von
unstimmigkeiten mit frau merkel sie sagt
dazu nichts
europa steht unter druck von innen und
außen dürfen sie bei exit populisten
dauer zoff mit jump da müsste das thema
europawahl den bürgern doch echt auf den
nägeln brennen jeder zweite deutsche
kennt keinen einzigen spitzenkandidaten
für die europawahl in knapp fünf wochen
den unionskandidaten manfred weber kennt
sogar nur jeder vierte
glückwunsch preuß cdu/csu plakat nur ein
viertel der deutschen kennt herrn weber
aber selbst mit diesem erbärmlichen wert
ist er quasi noch ein superstar
verglichen mit anderen hallo ich bin
jude will man der fraktionsvorsitzende
der sozialdemokraten und
sozialdemokraten im europäischen
parlament das tut mir leid
und obwohl man kennen und dass jetzt
kein witz 4 prozent der deutschen dabei
sitzt dieser mann seit 20 jahren im
europa-parlament ja sogar bullmann frau
sagt ich hab den typen schon mal
irgendwo gesehen aber ich weiß echt
nicht wo es jetzt gemein eines gemein
ist liegt natürlich auch wie so oft an
uns medien wie oft berichten wir dann
über dieses angeblich so wichtige eu
parlament und jetzt raten sie durchaus
spaß mal wo die cdu ihren ersten großen
wahlkampf termin für diesen so wichtigen
europawahlkampf hatte berlin london
paris fast in eslohe im sauerland ja
hier ein archivbild
mit stargast friedrich merz und was für
ein auftritt hier
märz geht die nahm ich zu müde und
stellt dann fest die musik hört einfach
nicht auf speed
er will endlich in europa reden aber die
kapelle ist noch lange nicht fertig klar
wenn du einmal im fernsehen ist dann
spielst du natürlich alle models in
stufen
und das ist der moment in dem fritzl
merkt scheiße in der zeit die ich bei
blackrock an zwei millionen verdienen
mit
laut wird
[Musik]
minuten lang ging das europawahl mit
sauerland tatsächlich ist die lage vor
dieser europawahl echt bedrohlich rechte
parteien wie unsere afd oder die
italienische lega tun sich zusammen um
die eu abzuwickeln
quasi die von putin bezahlte
internationale der nationalisten es geht
also um vier freunde warum ist das
trotzdem so ein unglaublich lauwarmer
nullinger wahlkampf denn nirgendwo
anecken und keinem wehtun will ihr
plakat der grünen europa die beste idee
die europa je hatte wow viel weniger
inhalt geht echt nicht quizfrage wie
viele grüne braucht man um sechs worte
an die tapete zu kleben 28 plus einen
eisberg
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kommt wir bauen das neue europa ein satz
wie aus der wüstenrot werbung europa
jetzt mit noch mehr europa aus diesem
buchstaben müll hätte man auch weit
schönere setzte bauen können zum
beispiel weil sie nicht mag auto
passeier hatten mehr inhalt
entschuldigung könig
gerade wegen der populisten müssten die
anderen parteien doch eine eigene vision
dagegensetzen antifaschismus alleine
reicht nicht wie viel europa brauchen
wir wollen wir eine europäische armee
und wenn ja wann wieviel gemeinsame
wirtschaftspolitik stattdessen phrasen
alarm
auch bei der fdp und dann haben wir ein
motiv noch mitgebracht meine damen und
herren unsere kampagne muss aufrütteln
europa hat zeit hat alles europa hat
alles außer zeit
warum ist die frau dann im stehen 1
getrennt
mein gott es ist wirklich ein
erschreckend müder wahlkampfreden bin
darüber mit matthias matschke von der
werbeagentur matschke herr matschke was
ist ihr eindruck ich sag mal so ein
künstlerisch also ganz ehrlich
mich hat es total geflasht die
radikalität mit der man hier den
drängendsten fragen unserer zeit aber so
komplett aus dem weg geht es fantastisch
mit plakaten wie zusammenhalt hashtag
europa ist die antwort auf was keine
ahnung
ist doch egal wunderbares plakat allein
die idee hier nicht katarina barley zu
nehmen sondern ihre tochter also es sei
denn das ist geschafft
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das
ge fotoschau ist es ist ein super slogan
zusammenhalt da ist alles drin
beziehungsweise nichts einfache
botschaften für einfache menschen spd
klimaschutz
ob man kennt oder spd frieden besser als
krieg die jetzt einfach nur spd frieden
nein das ist nur der erste teil einer
plakat trilogie nach wien kommt jetzt
noch freude und natürlich eierkuchen
sie haben es immer noch nicht begriffen
inhalts vermeidung ist der ganze witz
gerade die union will ja nicht wirklich
mehr europa deutsches steuergeld für
arbeitslose junge spanier
für europa ist man eher so allgemein
sowie für weiß ich jetzt nicht frauen
oder umwelt da muss es geben aber darf
nichts kosten
deswegen cdu frieden ist nicht
selbstverständlich nicht falsch aber
verpflichtet zu nichts also außer dass
wir nicht mehr in polen einmarschieren
danach steht das ist aber alles ein
bisschen dünner gegen afd und co ich
meine die wissen was sie wollen nämlich
die rückabwicklung der eu
die kampagne der afg ist super viel mehr
inhalt als die anderen afd
unser geld für alle geht es nach brüssel
das nenn ich niveau ab nächste woche
plakatieren sie dann was glaubst du so
blöd brüssel nicht eine mutter
mein vorschlag bei der letzten
europawahl machen wir einfach eine
inhaltslose kampagne für alle parteien
mit bewährten slogans die die menschen
kennen und lieben europa aus fels
quellwasser gebrauch oder europa für
singles mit niveau und natürlich europa
sorgt auf bevor geruch entstehe gut
matthias matschke damen und herren guten
tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des heute
show youtube kanals begeistern schließt
gefälligst ein abo ab sofort